it's clearly out of context otherwise
they would have released the entire
recording I know I'm off the grid for
August but fear not CNN is still a far
left activist organization pretending to
be a journalistic outfit after our
interview the Atlantic released the
audio more than four minutes of it
actually and here is the part with that
quote that was in question
about January we can handle it whatever
it is we can handle it but one human
agents how many government agents were
in the field right do you mean like
entrapment yeah
absolutely why can the government not be
transparent about something that we're
using
terrorists you know the kind of tax
abused by terrorists if we find that
there are hundreds of Our Own in the
ranks of the day that they were
you think that they were I mean
look there's a difference between
entrapment and difference between a law
enforcement agent identified I think it
is legitimate to say how many
police how many federal agents were on
the planes that hit the Twin Towers like
I think we wanted maybe the answer is
zero probably a zero for all I know
right I've noticed I think it was
anything other than zero
but if we're doing a comprehensive
assessment of what happened on 9 11. we
have a 911 Commission absolutely that
should be an answer the public knows the
answer to
oh okay they've evicted nothing wrong
there's nothing there's literally
nothing wrong with what he said there
but that's like we're doing this in
comparison to January 6th so we do want
to know how many federal agents were
involved in January 6 and imagine if
there was actually federal agents that
were involved on the planes in 9 11. he
didn't say there were no he specifically
said zero I'm sure it was Zero I'm sure
we'd want to know right but we'd want to
know and he's saying if you're claiming
this was an act of terrorism just like
that was an act of terrorism then okay
let's have a commission let's have a
report let's know how many federal
agents there were and so far I mean by
the way it's crazy does she keep going
can I hear what her take on that is
submitted on this video please play the
rest of it okay
I want to hear what she has to say about
this
herself he was in fact quoted accurately
in an email to CNN after that audio was
published his spokesperson said the
audio clearly demonstrates that Vivek
was taken badly out of context and even
this small snippet proves that we
continue to encourage the Atlantic to
release more of the recording rather
than their carefully selected snippet so
that the full context and reality is
exposed I should note that spokesperson
did not explain how he was supposedly
taken out of context the reality is that
Vivek ramaswamy is running to be
president of the United States he will
be on that debate stage tomorrow night
and he says this is a central message to
his campaign
this campaign is founded on the truth
the truth we will not back
we stand
for the truth
I'm a patriot who speaks the truth
well the truth is he did say it the
quote was accurate and it is on tape and
yes this is how
it works
it quoted for things you say accurately
yeah but that is still out of context
it's clearly out of context otherwise
they would have released the entire
recording I know and it's this weird
thing where they brag about how like but
you know what the Atlantic did release
four minutes of audio like well why not
just release the whole thing right but
this was after he had said they didn't
release it because they hadn't right so
he's asking for the copy of it they
would not give it to him and then they
released this small snippet that is
again taken out of context and it's not
as if anywhere in there he says I I
believe there were federal agents in uh
on January zero well on 9 11 he said
it's probably zero but he said he's
asking the question about January 6. but
he never even said I believe January 6th
was an inside job he said like it seems
like entrapment like that that's kind of
what it seems like and we have a right
to ask these questions